okay a barely audible uttering was an
iconic phrase that became part of
popular culture again please houston we
have a problem the launch was routine
this was to be the third moon landing
and the mission commander James Lovell
was on his fourth trip into space just
after my 55 hours into this mission that
the explosion occurred okay now it's
everybody keep core we an explosion in
an oxygen tank destroyed the outer
panels of the command module and shorted
many of the intricate electronics
keeping the craft in orbit the idea of
the moon landing was abandoned the
success of the mission was not to be
measured by survival the astronauts used
the lunar module as a lifeboat while
dozens of scientists back at Mission
Control worked out how to repair the
systems keep the astronauts alive and
get them back to earth find a way to
make this fit into the hole for this
using nothing but that
the world was transfixed by the drama
taking place in space Lord your
astronauts will come back save for a few
days all division was forgotten as
millions around the globe will the
astronauts a safe return home and fifty
years later a new generation of
astronauts inspired by lessons learned
from the Apollo 13 mission members of
NASA's Artemis program which is designed
to put a man and woman on the moon by
2024
followed by a mission to Mars we learn
more from our failures than we ever do
from our successes up in space
astronauts on the International Space
Station continue their work remembering
the Apollo 13 mission in a
videoconference and paying tribute to
the scientists on earth striving to keep
them safe in the face of a pandemic has
changed the way that Mission Control
operations
worked they're actually doing handover
between shifts between two different
rooms to minimize the contact but yet
here they are persevering and through
their ingenuity and their
professionalism
we're they're gonna return us to earth
safely just like their predecessors did
50 years ago I think about 30 was a very
good example of always expecting the
unexpected
when I saw the parachutes streaming out
that blossom
I am nude by this time that end last
week sunk in the Pacific Ocean we would
be successful a fifty-year-old message
that resonates in a world sheltering
from pandemic Mike Hanna al Jazeera
Washington